hey what's up Samuel leaves here and
this is a video for our certified
partners to teach you how to get a
runner while lying on your bed at home
like I'm doing right now tomorrow we've
got some we've got some viewings in
Grimsby and we've got a few things
booked I can't go no one can go so we
need a runner how do you get a run out
last minute well here we go watch this
this will blow you a way so first I'm
going to show my screen you can just do
this at home while on your bed so boom
you shouldn't I be able to see my screen
alright here goes
first thing you need to do is you need
to go on to a website called a spare
room doctor at UK which by now should be
your new best friend so don't spare room
and what you're gonna want to do is
you're going to want to find there's two
types of people that will be a really
good runner one is a property HMO
manager they'll be really good runners
because they'll be able to specify this
room a bit hmm or not secondly will be a
builder a local builder because they're
gonna know how much work it's gonna need
so we're gonna start by looking at
agents so if we type here Grimsby
Grimsby rooms for rent search now and we
can see here that we've got lots of
rooms available so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna type in at the top we can
click where it says agents only we don't
want to send a private landlord because
that's just a bit weird and they're a
competition and everything so it's been
send an agent who could potentially get
business from it I think certainly as a
first port of call so we see all these
properties in Grimsby we've got here 85
pound a week 65 70 pounds and you can
click on these and you can actually see
that here we go unity lettings phone
advertiser that's their number
gilma call boom they might be able to
view it for you I'll tell you what to
say in a moment when you call them but
there's absolutely loads
and also you can see a lot of these I
mean the property that we're looking at
is this one sixty five grand for bed
house it looks like it's in good
condition floor plans is great he had
five bedrooms out of it one two
that would count as one one two three
and then downstairs four five so it's
great it's a good area it's in dn-3 too
and we can see here that some of these
guys are also in D and 3/2 which is
perfect
the rooms are going 100 pound a week 95
pound a 800 pound a week and these are
actually less which is crazy that it's
in D and 3/2 and they're renting out for
that much with the house so cheap so we
really just want to get a second opinion
and HMO manager is the best person this
is another one new mills properties boom
okay we've got no number what we can do
instead is we can actually just google
these guys new mills properties and then
Shaba we've got their number okay
they're close now but that's not the
point I want four seven two three six
zero one six eight so you can do this
and you can get so many different
people's contact details of leyte HMO
managers nearby they're just brilliant
brilliant brilliant runners next build
us what do you do
wow you just literally type in Builder
Grimsby here we have a whole bunch of
builders I mean there's just so many to
choose from
Wi-Fi is a little bit slow but you get
the idea just Google Grimsby builders
and you'll see what there's so much this
directory after directory so the
question is okay we've got the - all
these guys the or as these are all in
Grimsby got their numbers got everything
about them Lee Easter and Sons oh seven
seven one seven one six two four two
nine so when you call them what do you
say if they're a letting agent I would
probably say something like this because
you're gonna want to break your way in
you can't discuss straight you know got
a house can you move for me tomorrow
that's a little bit but she could direct
so I'll doing up and I'll say building a
rapport hi I'd always start by saying
I've got HMO close by but not super
close so for instance Grimsby you could
say I've been doing HMOs for awhile I'm
a bit outside of the area maybe you
pulled or whatever and I'm buying a
property in Grimsby close to you and
that just wondered if it might work
cause I multi-layer his four bedroom
house that I'm looking a poem and let's
let's get your advice so it's in Church
Road or wherever and do you think that
would work
chance them if they think it would be
you've got a bit of rapport go and you
could say you know what I feel really
cheeky right now but I've actually got a
viewing on it
I've not seen it myself I've talked to
the agent I've got the funds for it
I see love you want it tomorrow I don't
suppose he's really cheeky and I'm very
happy to pay you and cover your expenses
I don't suppose that you could maybe
knit by and have a look for me and give
me some feedback I mean I totally
understand if not as I say I'm more than
happy to cover your expenses and if it
does go through and when complete on it
and you think you did good more to that
again you've given me some good advice
on it then of course I'll give it you to
manage what do you think and then boom
you've got a woman builder same story
ring up a builder and you're gonna say
hey do you work in the groomers B area
yes I do great do you work on Church
roads cuz I'm buying a property of there
yes sir excellent
you know I don't think it's too much
work and now I'd love to get you out to
have a look at that I'm gonna be upfront
with you I haven't actually bought it
yet it's still it's still going through
so you know it's not even how to even
you know
god they already think it's on the
market but before I put an offer on I
don't know how much I'm going to I need
to spend already to do it up so if you
could go out for me I'm more than happy
to pay you in cover your costs to go in
quote but I could definitely use you as
the Builder if it goes through I mean
how does that sound I just he just talks
people build relationships another way
to get runners go networking there's
lots of people that would love to you
know that absolutely love to view lots
of properties that are potential hang
banners they don't know our potential
like smoke what looks like as long as
you get everyone to go out to fill out
the feedback form so they move through
the whole checklist thing you good I'd
often be on the phone when they're there
so you can ask some questions
make sure to fill out the the form
properly so you know how much work needs
to be done you know fire-escape windows
all that fun stuff specially this hmm
but that ladies and gentlemen is how you
can very easily get runners in any area
in the country which saves you having to
go and leverages your time like crazy do
go yourself as well especially when you
fill in the initial days you want to go
you want to get filthy air you wanna go
networking but hey if you can leave with
your son by using somebody else's it is
well worth it this is a business you can
give from the beach so enjoy get some
runners and I look forward to seeing you
very very soon thanks
you